merci de nous recevoir ça me ferait
plaisir d'être avec vous je vais me
présenter je m'appelle donc Gilles je
suis médecin généraliste je l'ai
déclinais tout comme ça vous verrez mes
conflits d'intérêt je suis membre
militant associatif au collectif émises
contre le viol et SOS Femmes 93 je suis
enseignant à Sorbonne université et puis
je suis vendu au Conseil j'ai été de
2013 à 2019 et à nouveau depuis 2022
donc ça me permet d'un peu de rappeler
que le Conseil est constitué quand même
de membres qui sont
la totalité et bénévoles donc ça c'est
important avec des faibles moyens et que
malgré ses faibles moyens le Conseil a
fait des des rapports donc près 50% des
recommandations ont été reprises dans
des projets de loi ou même reprise dans
des dans des lois effectivement je vais
juste reprendre avant de passer la
parole à la mettre d'oeuvre du dernier
rapport reprendre un petit peu les
rapports il y en a eu sur l'IVG en 2013
sur la PMA en 2015
sur l'éducation à la sexualité et à
l'égalité donc on pourra en reparler ça
fait partie des points morts ou des
points à développer la santé des femmes
en situation de précarité en 2017
les actes sexistes dans le suivi
gynécologique en 2018
prendre en compte le sexe et le genre en
2020 c'est le rapport donc Catherine
Vidal va nous parler puisqu'elle en est
la Métro d'oeuvre et c'était important
je rappelle aussi les derniers travaux
sur le préservatif féminin c'est
important aussi d'en reparler ou les
derniers les derniers communiqués sur
l'IVG et la nécessité de
constitutionnaliser ce droit voilà
c'était important de vous dire que
pendant un certain temps le conseil
aussi a été en attente de nomination de
nouveaux membres et donc le travail a
tardé peut-être qu'on ne pourra pas
répondre à toutes les questions que vous
avez posées du fait des faibles au moyen
et peut-être aussi du fait de cette de
ce temps en tous les cas merci à vous je
vais laisser la parole à Catherine Vial
qui est vraiment la mettre d'oeuvre de
ce rapport et qui va nous donner un
éclairage éclairant sur sur ces travaux
merci Catherine merci beaucoup je crois
qu'il y a des personnes qui
voulaient vous interpeller non parce que
Madame faisait avant pardon
bon bonjour à toutes et à tous et merci
beaucoup pour cette invitation
on va rentrer tout de suite dans le vif
du sujet puisque
j'ai eu l'honneur d'être sollicité par
le H&M pour rédiger ce rapport intitulé
prendre en compte le sexe et le genre
pour mieux soigner un enjeu de santé
publique
alors ce rapport en fait part d'un
constat qui est celui de la persistance
des inégalités sociales de santé entre
les femmes et les hommes qui conduisent
à des discriminations dans l'accès aux
soins et la prise en charge médicale
l'importance de ces questions à conduit
à certains nombres de pays surtout Nord
pays Européens du Nord et Amérique
Canada donc ces pays ont intégré déjà
depuis pas mal de temps la thématique
genre et santé dans les prends plan
stratégiques des institutions de
recherche et de médecine et dans les
politiques de santé publique or dans ce
domaine la France est en retard
alors l'objectif de ce rapport est donc
de montrer que la prise en compte du
genre alliée à celle du sexe est source
d'innovation dans la médecine la
recherche et les politiques de santé
et j'ajouterai que ce rapport à une
spécificité à savoir qu'il repose sur
une approche scientifique au niveau
international c'est-à-dire que nos
sources sont toutes extrêmement robuste
ce sont des sources qui viennent
d'articles de recherche publiées dans
des revues internationales donc avec des
comités de lecture les enquêtes
épidémiologiques que nous citons sont
elles aussi validées quant à la taille
de l'échantillon et les tests
statistiques et les publications en
question sont récentes elles datent de
moins de 10 ans donc ces points sont
extrêmement importants pour comprendre
l'évolution des connaissances dans ce
domaine alors première
notion très importante il faut faire la
distinction entre
différences et inégalité dans la santé
les différences de santé sont liées au
sexe biologique au caractéristiques
qui sont propres au mal et aux femelles
au niveau des gènes des cellules des
organes des hormones etc mais quant aux
inégalités celles-ci relève de facteurs
sociaux culturels et économiques dans
lesquelles le genre joue un rôle
prépondérant il y a en particulier les
représentations sociales qui sont liées
au genre féminins et masculins qui vont
influencer à la fois les attitudes des
patients et les attitudes des soignants
la précarité économique qui touche comme
vous le savez particulièrement les
femmes et aussi les violences et
agressions sexuelles dont elles sont les
premières victimes et donc c'est
l'interaction complexe de tous ces
facteurs biologiques environnement
social lié au genre qui est donc source
d'inégalités de santé entre les femmes
et les hommes et hélas source aussi de
discrimination dans l'accès le soin et
la prise en charge médicale donc voilà
tout ça c'est déjà bien posé on va
maintenant voir quelques exemples la
durée de vie bon on connaît bien le
sujet les femmes vivent en moyenne plus
longtemps que les hommes il y a
l'espérance de vie à la naissance
l'écart est d'environ 6 ans
79.3 pour les garçons 85.4 pour les
filles mais ce qui est important de
considérer c'est l'espérance de vie en
bonne santé c'est-à-dire sans aucune
limitation ou incapacité majeure et à ce
moment-là l'écart se réduit il est
seulement de 1 an et demi
64,4% pour pour les hommes et 65.9 pour
les femmes donc les femmes vivent plus
longtemps certes mais elles passent plus
d'années que en mauvaise santé alors
comprendre pourquoi n'est pas une mince
affaire il y a d'une part probablement
le rôle de la diagnostic tardif de une
pathologie et à nouveau les notions qui
relèvent de la précarité économique avec
renoncement aux soins et mauvaise
hygiène de vie
autre exemple emblématique les maladies
cardiovasculaires qui sont la première
cause de mortalité chez les femmes le
cancer du sein n'est qu'à la 8e ou
dixième place selon les les enquêtes or
les femmes
développent plus tard que les hommes des
maladies cardiovasculaires environ 10
ans plus tard alors on peut se poser
évidemment à la question pourquoi donc
on a longtemps
favoriser l'hypothèse hormonale à savoir
que les hormones les estrogènes ont
effectivement un rôle vasoprotecteur par
rapport à
le dépôt de de plaques dans les artères
et l'idée étant que à la ménopause la
baisse des estrogènes rendrait les
femmes plus vulnérables
c'est un sujet compliqué parce que quand
on fait un traitement hormonal
substitutif celui-ci s'accompagne de
risque important d'AVC et autre point
depuis 15 ans l'incidence de l'infarctus
a augmenté de 25% chez les femmes de
moins de 50 ans donc cela signifie que
le rôle attribué aux estrogènes n'est
pas suffisant par rapport à d'autres
facteurs de risques liés en particulier
au mode de vie et cela nous ouvre de
nouvelles pistes de recherche et parmi
ces pistes de recherche il y a tous les
travaux qui montrent qu'il existe dans
les pratiques hélas un biais dans les
diagnostics et l'accès aux soins la
facture du myocarde en particulier est
sous le diagnostiqué parce que
considérer à tort comme une maladie
uniquement masculine d'hommes stressés
au travail dans la cinquantaine dans la
réalité pratique et ça ce n'est pas
anecdotique cela a été constaté dans de
nombreux pays pour des mêmes symptômes
d'oppression dans la poitrine se des
femmes en trois fois plus de chance
d'être attribué à des raisons
émotionnelles plutôt qu'à des troubles
cardiaques on note aussi un retard de
prise en charge des femmes par rapport
aux hommes à l'arrivée aux urgences en
cas de suspicion d'infarctus et il y a
aussi le fait que les femmes minimisent
les symptômes et appelle plus
tardivement les urgences
c'est différents points concernent de
nombreux pays on n'est pas simplement
dans des cas français donc cela
illustre à quel point les normes
sociales et les stéréotypes liés aux
gens vont influer à la fois les
attitudes des médecins et des malades
autre point l'autisme qui touche trois
hommes pour une femme on ne connaît pas
l'origine de la différence de prévalence
entre les sexes mais ce qu'on sait c'est
très documenté qu'il y a un retard au
diagnostic chez les filles des enquêtes
se peut portant sur des milliers
d'enfants monstres que ici aux
États-Unis 37% des cas sont étaient
détectées en bas âge contre seulement
18% des filles or plus on intervient tôt
mieux ça vaut évidemment et il y a aussi
donc le rôle des normes sociales liés au
genre à savoir que un jeune enfant qui
présente des comportements de retrait
sur soi de avec un défaut d'interaction
sociale chez une fille on va qualifier
ses attitudes de timidité ou de réserves
alors que chez un garçon on va
s'inquiéter en se disant il y a
peut-être un trouble de la communication
donc les symptômes sont plus discrets
chez les filles et donc plus difficile à
détecter par l'entourage et le corps
médical et les enseignants
autre point très illustratif également
très important la dépression qui touche
partout dans le monde deux fois plus les
femmes que les hommes on a longtemps
également mis en avant l'hypothèse
hormonale avec les femmes avec leurs
changements d'humeur bien connu liés aux
menstruations grossesse ménopause etc et
dans l'état actuel de nos connaissances
il n'y a pas de démonstration
scientifique d'un rôle unique des
hormones par rapport à d'autres facteurs
pour expliquer les risques de dépression
en fait on a mis en évidence un rôle
très important de l'environnement
culturel social et économique des études
internationales en particulier portant
sur la dans l'exemple 200 pays montre
que plus le niveau socio-économique est
élevé plus l'écart entre les femmes et
les hommes dans la prévalence de la
dépression se réduit et une étude
réalisée en comparant les pays d'Europe
du Nord et d'Europe du Sud ou dans ces
derniers les traditions familiales la
dépendance économique le travail
domestique les violences sont
particulièrement plus présents et bien
tous ces facteurs montrent une
corrélation forte avec la prévalence des
troubles dépressifs donc cela veut dire
que le contexte socio-économique expose
davantage les femmes que les hommes au
risque de dépression
la maladie d'Alzheimer qui touche trois
femmes pour un homme bon l'origine de la
différence de prévalence et l'objet de
recherche importante il y a évidemment
la plus grande longévité des femmes mais
ce n'est pas le seul facteur responsable
de nombreux travaux ont montré que il
existe des facteurs d'ordre sociaux et
culturels à savoir précarité économique
niveau d'instruction faible et manque
d'exercices physiques qui sont des
facteurs de risque accrus pour la
maladie d'Alzheimer et
ces différents facteurs de risque
touchent davantage les femmes
encore un autre exemple celui-ci on en
parle enfin un peu plus qu'auparavant
l'endométriose il faut quand même voir
sur le plan historique que c'est dans
les années 90 qu'il y a eu un début de
reconnaissance de cette pathologie en
tant que atteinte organique par le corps
médical
et ce n'est seulement que en 19 en 2019
il y a eu un premier plan national sur
l'endométriose en France et en 2022
comme vous le savez on a un deuxième
plan qui a été lancé qui reconnaît
l'endométriose comme une maladie de
longue durée et on notera aussi que ce
n'est qu'en 2020 que on a intégré
l'endométriose au programme du deuxième
cycle des études médicales voyez le
temps de latence qu'il faut pour rendre
qu'il a fallu pour reconnaître cette
cette maladie et en plus c'est une des
premières causes d'arrêt de travail pour
les femmes en France
donc on l'expliquait par des évidemment
par une longue histoire qui vient du 18e
siècle avec le tabou des règles les
femmes considérées avec leur sexe
toujours
faible tous les femmes toujours
souffreteuses avec leurs problèmes
gynécologiques et autres et la plaine
des femmes face à ces questions
d'endométriose face n'a pas été pendant
trop longtemps elle a été complètement
occultée et parmi les recommandations du
HCE j'en parle d'ores et déjà parce que
on est en plein dans le sujet
il est vraiment important en particulier
d'abord de soutenir la recherche sur
cette pathologie qu'on comprend très mal
mais aussi organiser des formations
auprès des médecins du travail puisque
il y a la réalité de la la les arrêts de
travail qui sont majoritairement
beaucoup liés à et aussi il faut former
les infirmières scolaires qui elles ont
affaire aux jeunes filles et comme on le
sait tout le secteur médecine du travail
et médecine scolaire et extrêmement
déficient depuis pas mal de temps il
faut vraiment faire un effort dans ce
domaine là
l'ostéoporose ça c'est aussi un sujet
dont on ne parle pas assez
les fractures liées à l'ostéoporose
touche une femme sur trois et un homme
sur cinq bon et les conséquences ça veut
dire des handicaps avec des coûts
extrêmement importants
donc un tiers des factures des fractures
ostéoporétiques de la hanche concerne
les hommes or hélas l'ostéoporose est
trop souvent considéré comme une maladie
de femmes ménopausées et il y a un vrai
sous diagnostic des hommes vis-à-vis de
l'ostéoporose mais de toute façon les
femmes ne sont pas non plus suffisamment
suivies en ce qui concerne et traiter
pour l'ostéoporose
on peut évoquer rapidement un sujet qui
a longtemps fait débat heureusement tout
tout va de mieux en mieux dans ce
domaine là la participation des femmes
et des hommes dans les essais cliniques
en fait tout part des années 50-60 avec
aux États-Unis l'essor de l'industrie
pharmaceutique ou les essais cliniques
ont commencé à être de plus en plus
nombreux et très développé et hélas ces
essais cliniques ont été émaillés par
deux énormes scandales Nathalie demiede
et le distilben avec les formations les
malformations des fœtus et des cancers
chez pour les pour les enfants et en
conséquence donc en 1977
la FDA l'Agence du Médicament américaine
elle est
décidé d'exclure les femmes en âge de
procréer des essais cliniques de face 1
et 2
et c'est seulement en 1993 que le
Congrès américain a fini par voter une
loi qui oblige d'inclure les femmes dans
les essais cliniques et aussi les
personnes de minorité ethnique et enfin
cette action donc importante de la part
du Congrès
a été possible parce que il y a eu une
dénonciation par les milieux féministes
américains dans le domaine de la santé
en particulier qui montrait que les
femmes étaient sous représentées dans
les essais cliniques et quelque part la
situation pouvait aussi s'expliquer
parce que le risque d'infarctus avant 70
ans était très faible et on
systématiquement dans les essais
cliniques il est très rare d'inclure des
patientes âgés à cause des problèmes de
corps morbidité et depuis une quinzaine
d'années dorénavant après tous ces
cette réalité de prise en charge des
femmes dans les essais cliniques il y a
une évolution très favorable du
pourcentage des femmes et par exemple en
ce qui concerne le cancer du poumon ou
elles étaient quasiment indemnes de
cancer du poumon auparavant l'inclusion
des femmes dans les essais cliniques est
passé de 33% en 90 à 48% en 2012 et
quand on regarde tous les chiffres qui
rassemblent dans le registre
international des essais cliniques qui
est tenu par l'OMS et le Naiche ou à
tous les essais cliniques doivent être
obligatoirement déclarer dans ce
registre international et quand on
regarde les chiffres d'inclusion des
femmes entre 2008 et 2018
toute pathologie confondues on voit que
l'inclusion des femmes est en moyenne
supérieure ou égale à 50%. alors cela
peut varier selon les années en fait ça
varie en fonction du type de pathologies
qui est la plus étudiée à un moment
donné si il y a des pistes de nouveau
médicament pour contre le cancer de la
prostate il y aura plus d'hommes dans
l'ensemble des essais cliniques c'est
bien clair donc il faut vraiment
réaliser que on est plus dans les
situations antérieures de
sous-représentation des femmes
alors le sujet donc c'est un sujet
évidemment que vous connaissez très bien
les problèmes de la précarité des femmes
après karité économique par rapport à
l'accès aux soins et à la prise en
charge médicale
j'irai rapidement vous connaissez le
sujet 70% des travailleurs pauvres sont
des femmes un tiers des familles
monoparentales c'est souvent les femmes
vivent sous le seuil de la pauvreté donc
cela entraîne un renoncement aux soins
une mauvaise hygiène de vie avec et là
c'est une alimentation déséquilibrée
consommation d'alcool tabac c'est
dansarité qui vont contribuer à une
dégradation de la santé physique et
mentale avec en particulier des gros
problèmes d'obésité diabète maladie
cardiovasculaires dépression etc
autre point qui n'est pas suffisamment
abordé les risques professionnels et la
pénibilité au travail les cancers
d'origine professionnelle sont souvent
sous évalués chez les femmes c'est en
particulier le cancer du poumon qui fait
l'objet de très peu d'études on notera
aussi que en ce qui concerne les agents
cancérogènes dans le secteur d'une
nettoyage dont on a souvent parlé mais
en l'occurrence on n'a pas d'étude
épidémiologiques suffisamment solide
pour documenter ces questions là une
étude de l'Inserm a montré que il y
avait une augmentation de 26% du cancer
du sein lorsque le en cas de travail de
nuit et bien sûr il faut vraiment former
les tous les autres les entreprises à
ces questions là c'est extrêmement
fondamentales
on sait aussi que les troubles
musculo-squelettiques sont plus
fréquents chez les femmes à cause
justement de type d'activités avec des
métiers ou il y a des postures
répétitives inconfortables
tels que à nouveau le nettoyage l'aide à
la personne etc les risques
psychosociaux qui sont plus fréquents
également chez les femmes à cause de des
postes peu qualifiés horaires atypique
parcours professionnel en rupture etc et
une étude récente a montré que le risque
de basculement d'un mal-être d'ordre
psychosocial vers un trouble avéré de la
santé mentale va concerner 26% des
femmes et 19% des hommes
je reviens donc sur ces notions donc de
pénibilité aussi au travail donc un
point important est de réaliser que les
critères de reconnaissance des maladies
professionnelles sont majoritairement
fondées sur le travail fait masculin et
donc il est très difficile pour les
femmes de le faire reconnaître
la charge domestique et familiale avec
la double journée de travail évidemment
joue un rôle particulier sur la santé
physique et mentale et les violences on
n'a pas on ne parle pas suffisamment de
des conséquences enfin on parle des
violences beaucoup évidemment pour la
prévention et pour la prise en charge
des femmes qui en sont victimes mais il
y a l'aspect santé mentale et santé
physique qui doit être aussi au même
titre pris en charge de façon vraiment
volontaire
donc les conclusions de ce rapport
est que justement cette notion de
cette dimension du genre qui n'était pas
forcément très acquises auparavant cette
dimension du genre alliée à celle du
sexe a donc des retombées majeures en
termes de connaissances scientifique de
prise en charge médicale et de
traitement de prévention et
d'optimisation des coûts de santé et
donc cela va nous permettre de
construire des politiques de recherche
et de santé plus égalitaires pour les
femmes et pour les hommes et donc nous
avons en conclusion de ce rapport
il y a 40 recommandations avec 4
recommandations phares intégrer la
thématique Jean récente dans la
formation aux professions médicales et
paramédicales
formation initiale des étudiants qui est
encore très peu développé formation
continue des professionnels de santé et
tout cela doit aussi inclure une
formation de la du dépistage
systématique des violences
il serait bon également de créer une
nouvelle institution publique de
recherche et de médecine sur la
thématique genre et santé qui
permettrait de réaliser quelque chose
qui est toujours difficile à mettre en
oeuvre à savoir une approche
pluridisciplinaire sur ces questions là
qui permettrait donc d'associer les
recherches cliniques biomédicales avec
les recherches en sciences sociales et
en santé publique il faut évidemment
garantir l'accès aux soins pour les
femmes précaires et favoriser aussi la
parité dans l'accès au poste de
responsabilité dans les professions de
santé et de recherche merci beaucoup
pour votre attention
décidément alors
je vous l'avais mis vous auriez pu le
mettre pour moi également au permis non
vraiment merci à tous les deux pour
cette présentation à devoir une
présentation très étayée très renseignée
et très fouillé et je vais peut-être
dans un premier temps laisser la parole
au rapporteur qui souhaite vous
interroger j'imagine sur ces
conclusions du HSE ces propositions et
ce diagnostic est quand même assez
éloquant et puis à bien entendu après je
passerai la parole aux autres sénatrices
qui le demandent où sénateur mais il y a
pas de sénateur ce matin dans la salle
merci donc tout d'abord Marie-Pierre
Richer
merci présidente merci Madame Madame et
Monsieur pour pour vos propos je vais
revenir justement sur sur vos propos on
a évoqué les essais cliniques et vous
vous avez dit dans vos propos et c'est
dans le rapport qu'il y a une évolution
de prise en compte justement du genre et
que les inégalités se réduisent en vous
appuyant sur les travaux d'Amérique du
Nord
USA et madame vous avez dit dans vos
propos que la France a du retard en la
matière jusqu'à quel point la France a
du retard et comment elle s'inscrit par
rapport au pays européens
ensuite j'avais noté
dans l'une de vos recommandations et
puis vous l'avez dit tout à l'heure
qu'il y a une prise en compte de bout en
bout de certaines maladies des femmes et
j'ai lu dans la presse récemment que
l'Institut Curie d'encologie espère être
retenu dans le cadre du programme
d'investissement d'avenir afin d'avoir
d'inventer la médecine de demain pour
une nouvelle structure entièrement
dédiée au cancer des femmes ça répond à
une des 40 de vos préconisations
avez-vous connaissance de la mise en
place d'autres projets
et puis
après c'est tout avec trois questions
votre rapport s'inscrit dans la lignée
si j'ai bien lu de ce de 2017 et 2018 et
dans le rapport vous parlez d'une clause
de revoyure au bout de deux ans nous
sommes au bout de deux ans qu'en est-il
et avez-vous d'autres travaux en
perspective merci
je préfère répondre à chaud
voilà comme je vous l'ai dit les essais
cliniques bon ça concerne une
institution
ça doit répondre aux critères des
institutions internationales
définies par l'OMS et le NA Edge et la
France en fait partie au même titre que
les autres pays et on n'a pas un retard
particulier dans les pratiques qui en
France
la notion de retard de la France par
rapport à d'autres pays européens au
nord américain
c'est la notion de d'avoir des
institutions publiques de recherche et
des institutions médicales qui soient
dédié à l'intégration de la notion de
sexe et de gens dans les stratégies
des institutions de recherche et dans
les politiques publiques donc c'est dans
ce sens là c'est à dire une des actions
gouvernementales pour donner un statut à
ces questions là
en ce qui concerne maintenant les toutes
les recherches menées sur le cancer les
cancers qu'il y ait comme l'Institut
Curie est en train de le développer des
thématiques davantage dédiées au cancer
féminin on ne peut que s'en réjouir
voilà et quant aux aspects
suivis enfin comment est-ce que les
recommandations que nous avons faites
ont été prises en compte
on a là il y a deux ans de décalage par
rapport aux conclusions de l'époque si
on veut avoir une idée des retombées
bah pour cela il faut des financements
il faut des financements il faut mener
des enquêtes sur le terrain il faut
faire des des études épidémiologiques il
faut
il faut aller sur le terrain pour voir
que ce soit auprès des institutions de
recherche que ce soit chez les
praticiens que ce soit dans les
associations et cette démarche là
a priori elle doit se faire avec une
volonté délibérée de de
dresser un état des lieux des avancées
ou des recul sur ces questions
merci beaucoup donc je poursuis avec les
rapporteurs donc Annick
merci madame la présidente Madame
Monsieur Merci pour pour vos propos pour
ce travail que vous avez fait qui je
pense va bien nous éclairer déjà dans un
premier temps alors j'ai eu une autre
question vous parlez très peu du sport
si ce n'est quand vous abordez la
maladie d'Alzheimer ou vous dites qui a
effectivement un manque d'activité
physique mais on a vu qu'il y avait un
écart d'un an et demi entre les femmes
et les hommes pour vieillir en bonne
santé et d'autres pathologies aussi qui
sont liées au sport est-ce que vous vous
êtes intéressé justement à cette
activité physique dans le cadre de vos
travaux pour voir quel est l'impact
justement que ça pouvait avoir ou si les
écarts que vous annoncez pouvaient être
dur en partie à ce manque d'activité
physique et puis je serais intéressé
aussi à connaître les causes vous nous
disiez qu'il y avait une augmentation de
26% de cancer du sein en cas de travail
de nuit
savoir à quoi est-ce qu'on attribue
cette augmentation du cancer du sein
est-ce que c'est la fatigue est-ce que
c'est le décalage du cirque du cycle
circadien
voilà dans un premier temps les
questions que m'inspire vos propos merci
alors en ce qui concerne le sport
qui évidemment les activités sportives
sont extrêmement importantes pour rester
en bonne santé
nous ne l'avons pas évoqué précisément
dans dans le rapport comme vous l'avez
souligné
je dirais que sur ce sujet comme sur
d'autres d'ailleurs
recueillir des données
est extrêmement difficile
parce que
quand on veut avoir des des échantillons
représentatifs d'une certaine catégorie
de la population
les uns les unes faisant du sport et pas
les autres
constituer des groupes de personnes
homogènes c'est extrêmement difficile en
soi quel type d'activités sportives ou
quand comment les personnes en tel des
comorbidités qui feraient que la le
bénéfice du sport puisse être
enfin puisse varier
quels âges quelle tranche d'âge et
étudier oui la difficulté de mettre en
place
simplement une enquête avec tous les
talents des gens qui font des enquêtes
qu'on a nous en France ce genre d'études
est extrêmement difficile à réaliser et
à nouveau il faut des financements si on
veut la réaliser donc on a on est en
manche de données là-dessus on a des on
peut avoir des des
espérer que des campagnes de permettront
de plus mobiliser les gens sur ces
questions là mais voyez mesurer et
regarder l'impact de de des campagnes
d'information tout ça c'est très très
difficile par l'immense hétérogénéité du
sujet
en ce qui concerne le l'augmentation du
cancer du sein
dans en cas de travail de nuit
ça je
suis au mieux vous adresser à l'Institut
Curie
aux auteurs de ses études qui
certainement enfin ils ont fait une
étude justement très qui a permis
d'obtenir des chiffres
avec des méthodes rigoureuses mais quant
à savoir
les raisons de de cette augmentation qui
est qui est constatée c'est certainement
comme on dit multi factorielle quand on
dit multifactorielle c'est on se cache
pas devant une ignorance c'est que c'est
vraiment multifactoriel et que arrivé à
démêler les différents facteurs c'est
quelque chose de de en soi extrêmement
difficile
sur l'activité des des jeunes filles ou
des femmes dans le sport on a
effectivement pas d'études scientifiques
mais on a quand même des études
sociologiques qui montrent que les
stéréotypes jouent un maximum et que
quand on analyse l'occupation des cours
d'école et les différents sports qui
sont réalisés par les jeunes par les
petites filles et par les petits garçons
on a quand même pas la même chose la
valorisation du sport chez les femmes
c'est quand même intéressant et je crois
que là manifestement quand on revoit en
plus les trois cadres qui ont été
présentés par les stéréotypes les
violences et la précarité on comprend
que là on a un travail à faire pour
améliorer la santé des femmes et le
sport en est un
donc je pense que vous avez répondu à
toutes les questions donc je poursuis
avec le tour de nos rapporteurs avec la
rapporteurs Laurence Cohen merci madame
la Présidente merci Madame et Monsieur
pour pour ce rapport qui est extrêmement
riche simplement de manière anecdotique
sur le sport et les stéréotypes j'ai une
de mes petites filles qui est en 5ème
donc elle va avoir 12 ans et elle m'a
rapporté ce week-end que elle voulait
elle voulait jouer au foot et que les
garçons l'ont exclu du du jeu elle a
beaucoup de caractères donc bon je
dirais c'est pas laisser faire et
mais après y compris ils lui ont dit
mais tu as bien fait quand même tu vois
parce que finalement leur animal puisque
elle a fini par les mépriser voilà s'en
sortir comme ça et ils lui ont dit mais
tu as eu raison finalement de pas venir
avec nous alors qu'elle était exclue au
départ parce que ça finit en jeu de
rugby et donc ça aurait pas pu c'était
pas dû c'était pas du foot c'était du
non mais c'est pour dire on est en 5e
voilà moi je trouve comme chaque fois
vos rapports extrêmement riches
extrêmement fouillé et c'est une source
d'inspiration pour pour les législateurs
que que nous sommes et je pense pour
tous ceux qui sont attachés à l'égalité
au droit des femmes alors je voudrais
simplement vous poser la question sur le
fait que cette étude se rapporte vous
l'avez vous avez pu l'envisager au
niveau à la fois de l'hexagone et des
territoires ultramarins où vous n'avez
pas pu pousser votre votre recherche à
ce niveau là parce que on sait que il y
a quand même des différences qui
existent en termes et au niveau social
au niveau économique etc mais ma
collègue victoire le sait bien mieux que
que nous mais nous sommes attachés à ce
que ça soit sur l'ensemble du territoire
donc c'est cette cette première question
que je voulais vous poser la deuxième
question c'est qu'effectivement
on voit bien que par rapport à tout ce
que vous avez ouvert à vos
recommandations etc que pour aller plus
loin il faut qu'il y ait une prise en
compte à mon avis gouvernementale qui va
poursuivre qui va amplifier qui va
compléter avec les moyens que que peut
avoir un gouvernement donc ma deuxième
question c'est est-ce que vous avez pu
le présenter à la ministre
Rome et qu'elle a été son son accueil et
quels engagements elle a pu ou voulu
prendre auprès auprès de vous et ma
troisième question c'est alors c'est
c'est en lien avec le travail que nous
pourrions produire est-ce que vous
pensez que par rapport à ce que vous
avez déjà fait ressortir et qui est
extrêmement riche vous êtes un petit peu
frustré parce que il y aurait un angle
mort je ne le vois pas moi
personnellement l'angle mort mais comme
vous vous avez eu ce travail approfondi
peut-être que vous sentez qu'il y a
quelque chose que vous auriez aimé voir
développer davantage et que
malheureusement vous n'avez pas pu faire
donc je vous remercie par avance
alors en ce qui concerne les territoires
ultramarins
on ne peut que constater un manque de de
recherche et d'études menées sur place
en lien avec toutes les questions que
j'ai pu évoquer
on sait bien que hélas les moyens ne
sont pas alloués
comme sur le territoire pour
essayer de de
démêler de démêler un petit peu
justement ces questions liées à
l'environnement social culturel
économique et de le mettre en
perspective par rapport à la santé
donc c'est un effort qui doit
effectivement doit vraiment être fait
les les études internationales
et sont très présentes aussi dans mon
rapport
c'est important à titre de comparaison
pour vraiment
montrer à quel point il n'y a pas
forcément des spécificités
franco-françaises
hexagonale que dans de nombreux pays en
tout cas dans des pays
plutôt nantis mais on a aussi des
problèmes de dépression dans les pays du
Sud donc voyez c'est tellement important
d'avoir des sources de de connaissances
qui soient très élargi
et parce que sinon on peut pas vraiment
se rendre compte des points qui vont
être les points majeurs à aborder
vraiment dans des mesures d'informations
et de prévention parce que ça c'est un
extrêmement important
et il faut pas faut vraiment toujours
s'intéresser à l'international pour
comparer
et ensuite ça va nous guider
en ce qui concerne maintenant la
portée de ce rapport
bon nous l'avons remis à Monsieur Véran
et Madame Moreno à l'époque en 2020
mais nous n'avait pas nous n'avons pas
jusqu'à présent d'entretien avec
l'équipe de Madame Rome
et quand aux angles morts
bon il y en a il y en a forcément c'est
à dire que dans ce rapport bon nous
n'avons pas
trop
accordé de place à tout ce qui concerne
la santé sexuelle et reproductive parce
que ces questions là avaient déjà été
l'objet de nombreux rapports
précédemment
et donc je laisserai la parole à agir
sur ces sur ces questions là c'est
évidemment un sujet extrêmement
important ce qui est très important
aussi c'est l'éducation
à la santé sexuelle
dans à l'école et dans de très
nombreuses endroits enfin l'éducation à
la santé sexuelle c'est c'est
fondamental et hélas en tout cas en
France c'est pas
c'est pas fait
merci beaucoup pour ces
sur les différents rapports on les a
présentés aux différents ministres en
2016 en 2017 à tous les moments on les a
présentés est-ce qu'il y a eu des suites
depuis qu'on les a présentés il y a eu
quelques films puisque des
recommandations ont été reprises dans
les lois mais évidemment pas toutes et
là si on reprend pendant les quatre
recommandations phares sur la formation
initiale des étudiants en jean exantées
on n'a pas beaucoup d'études moi si je
regarde dans la fac où je travaille
effectivement il y a une petite
amélioration avec des enseignements sur
sur la prise en charge des femmes en
matière cardiovasculaire mais bon c'est
où quelques du des diplômes université
les étudiants qui font une spécialité en
cardiologie commence à être formés j'ai
interviewé quelques quelques collègues
d'hier mais j'ai pas vu vraiment un
grand vent donc là faut que vraiment on
accompagne et qu'on s'assure comme pour
les violences envers les femmes qu'on
s'assure que c'est réellement fait dans
les difficultés ces personnes dépendants
et s'il y a pas de questions d'internat
aussi à pas d'évaluation
réelle de ce qui se fait dans ces
facultés ont ça mettra un temps fou on
voit bien sur les violences depuis
l'étude en veille bien évidemment
aujourd'hui il y a des recommandations
de la SAS mais on sait pertinemment que
un grand nombre d'étudiants ne reçoivent
pas cette formation donc là on a on a
vraiment des recommandations à suivre et
pour les suivre il faut des moyens
encore une fois j'ai commencé à parler
du Haut Conseil en disant que il n'y
avait que des bénévoles trois charges de
mission ce n'est pas suffisant et quand
j'interroge mes collègues aussi sur les
études
en direction des femmes il y a manque de
budget pour les problématiques
cardiovasculaires très clairement donc
il faut vraiment que on s'assure que
c'est réalisé sur la formation médicale
continue c'est la même chose là aussi
pour tous les sujets importants comme
j'aurais senti violence ou inégalité
sociale de santé
les formations pour les professionnels
médicaux libéraux ces trois jours par an
point trois jours par an il y a
énormément d'indemnisés et c'est pas
obligatoire ça devrait l'être mais ça
n'est pas très clairement donc trois
jours par an c'est pas suffisant avec
l'ensemble des sujets donc là aussi soit
on veut améliorer l'accompagnement la
prise en charge de famille de violence
lutter contre les inégalités sociales de
santé montré au médecin à quel point on
est
pétri de stéréotypes quand j'interroge
mes collègues je leur dis est-ce que tu
as l'impression que tu soignes de la
même façon les femmes et les hommes
regarde évidemment et ben non dans les
fesses c'est pas vrai et on le prouve et
la présentation et le compte de
Catherine lemontre très clairement il
faut déconstruire donc pour déconstruire
il va falloir réellement créer une serre
nommer des enseignants sur ces sujets
participates études là aussi sur les
thèses j'ai essayé de regarder les
thèses sur cette femme on commence à
avoir
c'est pas suffisant mais ça bouge sur
Jean et santé à part des études sur la
transidentité il y a rien sur non mais
c'est quand même un incroyable il y a
pas grand chose donc là aussi s'il n'y a
pas une indication claire et ferme de
ministère de des universités de la
recherche de la santé pour s'assurer que
c'est mis en place ça ne se mettra pas
en place je reprends toujours l'exemple
dans les années 90 quand on a commencé à
mettre en place les traitement de
substitution par les patients
toxicomanes
rien n'était fait et à un moment donné
le mystère de la Santé a dit non on va
organiser à côté des formations
on va organiser d'autres formations qui
étaient prises en charge par le
ministère de la Santé la DGS pour
permettre aux médecins de se former et
on a nommé des médecins qui allaient
dans toutes les provinces pour former
les autres collègues ok c'est des
démarches qui sont actives ou on ne dit
pas simplement faite mais on s'assure
que c'est réellement fait on met les
moyens pour que ça soit fait donc la
chair enjoressanté on l'attend toujours
alors sur l'accès aux soins des femmes
précaires là aussi quand on voit le nom
recours
comment dire aux prises en charge un par
les femmes et les hommes mais là en
l'occurrence les femmes quand on voit
que les femmes sont les premières
touchées par la précarité on doit
travailler sur le métier du travail on
l'avait déjà dit en 2017 les critères de
pénibilité ne sont pas adaptés aux
femmes les femmes sont par exemple comme
les autres très clairement et
aujourd'hui avec on a vu pendant le
covid l'aggravation de l'état de santé
des personnes de travailler dans le soin
et c'est essentiellement des femmes
la non prise en charge des transports
des temps de transport dans les journées
c'est quand même incroyable le
fractionnement du travail dans la
journée les troubles psychosociaux ne
sont toujours pas pris en charge comme
maladie professionnelle ou reconnu en
tant que tel là aussi la pénibilité et
les critères doivent être revus c'est
pas fait ça fait 2017 2002 on est 5 ans
après on y est toujours pas et alors
quand tu as parlé la parité ou la
rémunération vous savez qu'on n'y est
pas encore donc là aussi s'il y a pas de
de comment dire de position
volontariste et puis de pénalité très
clairement un financière envers toutes
les institutions ou les associations ou
les entreprises pour qu'il y ait égalisé
le salaire ben on y arrivera pas et sur
la lutte contre les stéréotypes je suis
un peu long je m'excuse là aussi si on
reprend le rapport qu'on avait fait sur
l'éducation et la sexualité on voit
encore aujourd'hui
que près de 60% des établissements qui
ne mettent pas en place
ces actions donc si on veut que ça bouge
il faut que ça bouge et que ça bouge dès
le début et très tôt
j'ajouterai
qu'on peut quand même saluer
une initiative
qui est celle de
d'une personne
qui s'appelle Nathalie bajosse qui est
une chercheuse en
sociologie en santé qui a beaucoup
travaillé sur les questions santé
sexuelle et reproductive mais qui a créé
récemment un très gros groupe de de
recherche qui associe à la fois médecin
chercheur sociologies épidémiologie
santé publique avec pour objectif donc
de d'étudier comment se forge les
inégalités de santé depuis la naissance
jusqu'à la sénescence
donc c'est un très beau projet il
s'appelle l'acronyme c'est jendi gen DHI
enfin je parle dans le rapport et en
fait ce projet était financé par
l'Europe
donc l'Europe ce projet a été
sélectionné parmi plusieurs centaines
donc
cocorico on est très content que des
sommes importantes je crois c'est
environ 10 millions d'euros pour 6 ans a
été alloué à ce très beau programme de
recherche très ambitieux qui est déjà en
train de porter ses fruits parce que
grâce à ce financement on a pu financer
des étudiants pour faire des thèses
inviter des postes doctorants dans les
laboratoires
organiser des des collaborations
internationales des Colocs bon donc
c'est ce domaine de recherche là il est
superbement bien menée par toute
l'équipe de Nathalie bajosse mais c'est
un financement européen
et donc bon c'est mieux que rien mais on
aimerait bien qu'il y ait aussi au
niveau national des une mise en place de
d'une volonté réelle de soutenir tout ce
qui concerne enfin les recherches je
veux dire au sens très large c'est pas
ce qui compte dans tous ces dans tous
ces questions on l'a bien vu c'est la
pluridisciplinarité c'est il faut
vraiment que les gens dialogues parce
que la santé c'est pas comme on le sait
seulement une affaire de biologie loin
de là c'est d'abord et avant tout une
affaire de société et
il faut vraiment faire ce qu'il y a un
effort qui vient de des instances
dirigeantes
sur la lutte contre les stéréotypes et
la prise en charge médicale
il a été annoncé que des cellules se
seraient mises en place au niveau des
universités pour lutter contre les
violences sexuelles et sexistes
on n'a pas l'habitude aujourd'hui la vue
réelle mise en place ce serait bien
qu'on qu'on ait des informations parce
qu'on sait que dans un grand nombre de
facultés c'est toujours pas mis en place
et c'est important de savoir que la
lutte contre les stéréotypes elle est
importante aussi en médecine et je veux
juste vous donner quelques chiffres
d'une étude qui a été réalisée par deux
étudiants de sarahudin et Amélie Jouault
auprès de
2000 internes en médecine générale sur
l'ensemble de leurs études
ils ont été interrogés sur ce qu'il
pouvait vivre pendant leurs études et 60
40%
déclarent du harcèlement moral 18% du
harcèlement sexuel c'est un cinquième de
la promotion c'est quand même un
cinquième promotion 18% de harcèlement
sexuel 62% de discrimination notamment
majoritairement liée aux gens ou à
l'apparence donc c'est pour vous dire
que on a un travail important à faire
lors des études avec dans dans le cadre
des enseignants et des étudiants et que
ça forcément ça intervient aussi sur la
prise en charge des femmes et des femmes
victimes de violence et une des
premières études que j'avais dirigée de
slender qui avait amené la parution du
livre omerta c'était de montrer que les
étudiants vivaient des violences et les
discriminations qu'ils voyaient des
femmes victimes de violence et que bien
entendu la prise en charge n'était
absolument pas adéquate on est vraiment
dans un il faut qu'on travaille dans
tout dans tous ces champs et c'est
important que ces cellules se mettent en
place pour faire bouger les choses et
c'est vrai que on parle de féminisation
du corps médical et tant mieux mais
clairement encore une fois le nombre de
postes de pays où le nombre de chefs
bien sûr reste encore majoritairement
masculin et ça et ça c'est à c'est
important que ça bouge et je reviens sur
ces cellules de prise en charge des
violences sexistes et sexuelles si elles
ne se mettent pas en place on n'arrivera
pas à faire en sorte que dans ces
services ces ambiances sexistes et ces
agressions cessent donc c'est vraiment
important et quand elle la prise en
charge des patientes aussi s'améliorera
bien évidemment
merci beaucoup pour ces éléments de
réponse très complets je passe la parole
à la quatrième rapporteur Laurence
Rossignol merci madame la Présidente
bonjour à vous deux
moi je vais pas par rapport aux
questions composées mes collègues une
chose d'abord on a décidé de travailler
sur la question de la santé des femmes
mais on a bien conscience que on n'est
pas sur un sujet vierge et qu'avant nous
d'autres ont travaillé de manière
peut-être panique tu l'as dit dans la
dans un intro c'est ce que j'ai raté et
dont on travaillait d'autres travaillent
aussi parallèlement puisque l'Assemblée
nationale de la délégation aura des
femmes à l'assemblée que vous allez vous
a peut-être déjà auditionné ou qui
veulent faire travail aussi sur ce sujet
là c'est que depuis le rapport sur la
pornographie on adore les SCOOP on a
pris goût on a pris goût à l'exposition
médiatique et au fait de porter des
sujets qui sont dans
des angles morts des sujets
ignorés et c'est pour ça je vais reposer
un peu peut-être autrement la même
question que Laurence qu'est-ce qui
aujourd'hui vous semble ne pas avoir été
encore suffisamment étudié et qui soit
étudiable par nous parce qu'on n'est pas
on n'est pas un centre de recherche on
n'a pas d'échantillons sur lesquels on
puisse travailler en particulier dans la
dimension intersectionnelle des
questions de santé ensuite j'appelle la
dimension intersectionnelle c'est
simplement le fait de des mécanismes
croisés c'est-à-dire voilà femme et
migrantes c'est un sujet intersectionnel
femme et handicap c'est un sujet
intersectionnel voilà qui sont pas
forcément sont pas des niches à mes yeux
c'est des dimensions du sujet je voulais
vous interroger sur deux questions
également qu'est-ce qui a été fait mes
collègues ont pensé que je ne lâche rien
et c'est vrai
voilà qu'est-ce qui a été fait étudier
sur Jean récentimental
aujourd'hui et
deuxième question un petit peu plus de
comment les questions genre sexe et
santé se percutent
vous comprenez Catherine
je
la repose autrement nous avons le sexe
nous avons le genre et le genre et le
sexe sont aujourd'hui dans des approches
dissociées comment c'est toutes les
questions tombent toutes les questions
autour de transidentité voilà par
exemple poser la question simplement où
est-ce qu'on classe en matière de santé
une personne trans est-ce qu'elle est
classée dans son genre ou dans son sexe
et comment on étudie la médicalisation
de la transidentité aujourd'hui alors je
suis pas sûr qu'on ira sur ce sujet là
c'est parce que c'est
oui mais c'est dans le débat c'est dans
le débat
mais voilà c'est trop risqué
tous les deux là-dessus quand même même
si on traite pas le sujet mais moi j'ai
une vraie
dans les questions de santé sexuelle et
reproductive par exemple
ou en fait où on met où on identifie
comment on identifie les dissonances de
sex biologiques de naissance et de genre
par la suite
désolé
donc sur les aspects
bon intersectionnel
à savoir essayer de
d'élargir la compréhension de de
certaines des problèmes de santé donc
dans un cadre non seulement
biologique mais social culturelle
économique avec des données qui
permettent aussi
de mesurer de façon plus précise
justement ces aspects liés à
l'appartenance ethnique
aussi les questions liées au handicap
c'est-à-dire qu'il faut qu'on arrive à
mener des études et plus
épidémiologiques des enquêtes sur le
terrain qui puissent intégrer tous ces
différents paramètres pour pour enrichir
nos connaissances
c'est ce que c'est de faire le groupe de
Nathalie Bajos
avec justement
un rôle extrêmement important
des enquêtes démographiques économiques
qui vont
sociologiques qui vont être alliés
aux données médicales et aux données de
recherche biomédicales la clé elle est
là pour
c'est une approche pluridisciplinaire et
pour avoir cette approche
pluridisciplinaire et bien il faut s'en
donner des moyens donc il faut
que les projets soient financés
les questionnements sont là sur le plan
intellectuel pour essayer de mieux
comprendre et faire avancer les choses
on passe rien sous silence mais encore
faut-il avoir les moyens de réaliser
tous ces travaux
bon la notion aussi de santé mentale bon
on sait à quel point la psychiatrie est
dans une
triste situation
la santé mentale bon moi en tant que
neurobiologie que j'ai aussi une petite
idée de ce que c'est
c'est un peu ce que j'évoquais
précédemment c'est la difficulté
de
mener des études avec des
critères qui permettent d'avoir des
données suffisamment robustes
avec à nouveau cette notion
d'échantillons homogène vous voyez quand
on fait des études il faut un
échantillon sur lequel on va travailler
et il faut un échantillon témoin de
personne qui
permettront la comparaison et puis aussi
il faut faire un suivi dans le temps
parce que la santé mentale c'est quelque
chose qui évolue enfin les autres
questions aussi enfin bon oui mettre en
oeuvre des études de cet ordre ça
demande d'énormes moyens alors j'ai
évoqué la question de la dépression bon
certes la dépression ça aussi c'est
quelque chose d'extrêmement hétérogène
et c'est grâce
je dirais à des à des coopérations à des
études de
internationales
qu'on pourra mieux comprendre justement
par exemple quand j'insistais sur la les
facteurs de risque liés à la à la
situation socio-économique
quelque part c'est nouveau
qu'on est des données qui portent sur
des échantillons de milliers de
personnes
avec vraiment des des traitements
statistiques et des études magnifiques
qui justement ont
pris en compte la réalité de des modes
de vie des personnes et tenter de faire
des corrélations avec les dépressions
donc c'est si on prend que la santé
mentale que la dépression dans
l'incendie mentale déjà c'est
extrêmement difficile de de sortir de
quelque chose de solide
est-ce qu'on considère que je suis
certain qu'on considère que le suicide
est une question de santé
je pense oui d'accord par exemple en
matière de suicide est-ce qu'on peut
est-ce qu'il y a des analyses genrées
sur le suicide oui oui alors aux
États-Unis en particulier au Canada
aussi
il y a des études souvent très
contradictoires parce que
on aurait parfois tendance à associer
des pressions des pressions majeures bon
mais il y a aussi des cas de
schizophrénie des cas bipolaires qui
peuvent être associés ensuite à des
comportements suicidaires mais le souci
ce n'est pas uniquement enfin c'est là
aussi c'est très hétérogène ce n'est pas
uniquement lié à une pathologie mentale
et
il faut se faire il faut faire très
attention à pas assimiler les deux
et bon ça c'est les spécialistes qui qui
débattent depuis pas mal de temps de ces
questions là
parce que justement on a de plus en plus
de données maintenant
quand on a peu de données en attendant
savoir des raisonnements un petit peu
réducteurs si je dis un petit peu simple
si nos connaissances s'enrichissent
c'est devient plus complexe et là les
nuances peuvent se faire et c'est on
progresse dans nos connaissances c'est
c'est des sujets de toute façon
extrêmement compliqués
en ce qui concerne maintenant les
aspects des personnes avec
les notions de sexe de genre et de
transidentité
je reviens toujours à ce que je disais
tout à l'heure on a quasiment aucune
donnée sur
la
l'accès aux soins de ces personnes sur
des prises en charge médicales en
fonction de pathologies qui leur
seraient propres ou bien qui ne leur
sont pas forcément propres
on a très très peu de données et y
compris au niveau international donc
c'est quelque chose qui est à nouveau
parce que ces personnes c'est des des
populations extrêmement diverses
donc
recueillir des données solides c'est
difficile et je pense qu'il nous faudra
du temps à
pour sortir quelque chose de
tout ça c'est en train de bouger et
bien sûr bon les
il y a bon moi je fais partie d'un
groupe international
qui s'appelle le New gendarines qui
s'intéresse à la à
tout ce qui les recherches en
neurosciences y compris en santé mentale
en lien avec le sexe et le genre et on
commence évidemment à s'intéresser à ces
questions de transidentité pour
essayer justement de de
favoriser des recherches dans ce domaine
là en donnant des bourses
des doctorats pour pour des étudiants
il faut alimenter nos connaissances
sur ces questions là pour l'instant
c'est très ça reste très ponctuel
je répondrai pas à toutes les questions
juste une remarque sur famille grand et
violente on avait fait des études qui
montraient très clairement que les
familles grandes
subissaient plus de violence au pays
subissaient plus de violences sur le
trajet et encore plus de violence en
France avec des agresseurs
supplémentaires qui étaient les
hébergeants bon donc il y a des études
sur la précarité là aussi on a plein
d'études qui montrent que la santé des
familles grandes est beaucoup beaucoup
moins bonne et que les programmes de
prévention ont encore une fois
s'adressent où ont un bénéfice plus
important chez les personnes qui ont
dans le moins besoin que sur les
personnes qui ont le plus besoin parce
que c'est ces campagnes de prévention
s'adressent pas à ces femmes avec les
bons outils les bons moyens et là on a
on a des problèmes de toujours cette
fameuse égalité
au fait la même chose pour tout le monde
non il faut pas faire la même chose pour
tout le monde encore une fois il faut de
les quitter il faut faire plus pour ceux
qui en ont plus besoin
et en l'occurrence quand on regarde le
suivi des femmes
en termes de prévention du cancer du col
de vaccination ou de mammographie on
s'aperçoit que les familles grandes ont
de moins bon à moins grand nombre de
dépistages et quand on regarde même les
enfants on s'aperçoit qu'ils ont aussi
ses enfants ses filles ont un grand
nombre de dépistage que des personnes
qui sont françaises depuis bien bien
plus longtemps sur la santé mentale à
travers l'étude qui a été montrée par
Catherine et bien sûr il y aurait encore
beaucoup d'autres études à faire
il y a des déterminants de santé les
déterminants de santé sont très très
comment dire sont très nombreux alors la
santé ou l'action des médecins c'est une
chose mais l'action de la société c'est
encore plus et on sait pertinemment que
quand on a un travail quand on a un
logement quand on a
l'électricité par exemple ou quand on a
tous ces éléments là ça améliore
considérablement la santé des personnes
et là
si on se réfère à aux travaux qui
avaient été réalisés par le Conseil
encore une fois sur les femmes et sur
les métiers du soin on voit que sur tous
les métiers qui par exemple qui ont été
qui ont persisté pendant le confinement
du covid on voit que leur état de santé
c'est aggravé donc là aussi on a des
choses à faire en plus et puis voilà
donc je répondrai pas à l'autre question
dis beaucoup
on a d'autres demandes de d'intervention
donc je vais passer la parole à
Marie-Pierre Monnier
et ensuite victoire jasmin merci madame
la Présidente merci pour cette exposé
c'est vraiment très très intéressant moi
j'aurais trois petites questions alors
d'abord vous avez parlé de diagnostic
tardif dans votre PowerPoint vous avez
surtout mis l'accins de certaines
pathologies sur l'autisme les maladies
cardiovasculaires et puis il y avait
autre chose dépression est-ce qu'il y a
d'autres maladies pour lesquelles ce
diagnostiquent est tardif et voilà ce
que vous avez travaillé dessus et
comment vous l'expliquer
vous avez parlé là dans votre
augmentation dans vos recommandations de
favoriser la parité d'un accès au poste
de responsabilité vous monsieur vous
avez dit d'une grande féminisation du
métier moi j'aime est-ce que vous avez
des chiffres c'est à dire combien de
femmes qui sont médecins parce qu'après
je pourrais vous les envoyer
au Conseil où on avait noté le nombre de
chefs de cliniques le nombre de pH et
ensuite le nombre de chefs de services
on pourra
dont vous parlez là du plafond de verre
en fin de l'accès au poste
responsabilité et dans la prise en
charge des femmes moi il me semble aussi
que les médecins généralistes se
féminisent donc il me semble que
justement on devrait arriver à pallier
alors la féminisation ne suffit pas il
faut aussi qu'il y a une formation ne
sait faire que ce qu'on nous a appris et
si on apprend pas on est aussi dans ce
cadre-là OK et après parmi tous les
recommandations là on est en plein PLF
alors c'est un peu spécifique
c'est-à-dire que tout ce qui est de
l'ordre du règlementaire ne peut pas
être repris dans le PLF mais ce qui a
des réglementations importantes qui
n'ont pas encore été reprises puisque
vous avez dit que 50% étaient tout à
l'heure je sais pas si c'est à propos de
rapport qui pourrait être porté dans le
PDF merci
en ce qui concerne les diagnostics
tardifs
et bien
comme je l'évoquais en fait ça
s'explique d'une part par toutes les
stéréotypes et les représentations
sociales de ce que représente
précisément une maladie féminine par
rapport à une maladie masculine donc
tant que c'est cet obstacle lié au
stéréotypes sur les maladies perdues on
va continuer à dire ça c'est une maladie
d'hommes ça c'est une maladie de femme
donc
les deux exemples emblématiques c'est
les maladies cardiovasculaires sous
diagnostic chez les femmes et
l'ostéoporose sous diagnostic chez les
hommes
et ces deux ces deux types de
pathologies sont vraiment c'est au cœur
de la santé publique c'est c'est quelque
chose la prise en charge est extrêmement
coûteuse de ces deux types de
d'attentative il faut vraiment
mettre l'accent
les pathologies mentales aussi enfin il
faut vraiment mettre le sens où comment
faire vraiment pour réduire aussi les
coûts
de santé par rapport à
cibler des campagnes de prévention et
d'information qui qui permettent de
réaliser
qui permet que la santé publique soit
mieux prise en charge et ça c'est c'est
ça reste enfin à nouveau c'est une
volonté politique qui doit y avoir
derrière
et l'autre bah oui ça c'est ça
merci merci beaucoup madame la
Présidente et merci j'ai entendu réponse
que vous avez donné un collègue donc je
n'ai pas quelque chose à ajouter sauf
que nous avons la présidente et moi-même
rencontré il y a environ un mois et demi
des femmes d'une association de la
police nationale il a concernant les
difficultés qu'elle rencontre c'est
c'est lié à la non prise en compte
justement de leurs compétences d'une
part mais aussi par rapport au risque
professionnel lié à leur équipements
quelquefois ils ont des kilos
d'équipements et là vous avez parlé de
posture dans le milieu musical
paramédical et aussi par rapport à la
durée de certaines tâches qu'elles ont à
faire par exemple pour faire la planque
par exemple de prendre un homme c'est
facile pour une femme qui est assez
règles qui souffre d'endormir Clio qui
doit se changer donc elles nous ont
expliqué un petit peu les dans la prise
en compte de certaines
particularités de leur métier et en
matière de promotion le problème se pose
également concernant je remercie
Laurence Corinne pour la partie qui
concerne les outre-mer c'est vrai que
bon les budgets ne vous permettent pas
non plus trop de vous déplacer c'est
dommage mais
concernant l'activité physique et
sportive alors il y a l'activité
physiquement
dans le bénéfss mais pour la pratique
volontaire activité sportive nous avons
fait en 2018 je crois un rapport sur le
football la possibilité du football par
les femmes et nous avons vu qu'il y
avait de très grandes disparités dans la
prise en compte des femmes alors
Laurence a donné un exemple mais les
équipements ne sont pas forcément
fait et équipés pour les femmes
elles-mêmes par exemple les vestiaires
pour les femmes les femmes qui veulent
faire du sport
football par exemple quelques fois ils
ont complètement exclues d'autres fois
et réussissent quand même mais n'ont pas
d'espace pour le entraînement elles
n'ont pas de vesti adaptés donc en fait
la société a construit un monde pour
plus pour les hommes que pour les femmes
donc il y en a qui réussissent à quand
même réussi dans ce domaine là mais
c'est compliqué c'est très compliqué et
dans certaines recommandations de notre
rapport et nous avons cette nombre
d'éléments qui peuvent étayer ces
arguments voilà et la dernière chose
concernant les femmes qui sont en
précarité alors le lien avec les
dépressions alors l'alimentation
pourrait aussi contribuer j'ai eu
l'occasion de lire alors bon j'oublie
quel document c'était mais que des
femmes qui avaient une approvision de la
qualité de leur alimentation et qui
manquait de ont été obligés quelquefois
pour être traité et bien la rencontre
par rapport aux pathologies mentale
d'avoir des probiotiques pour compenser
alors je ne sais pas ce que ça vous
comme études parce que j'avais lu ça
comme ça dans un domaine bien dans ce
journal pardon j'oublie de quoi il
s'agisse exactement mais je ne sais pas
si il y a un lien avec l'alimentation je
sais pas voilà merci
bon rapidement ce que vous soulignez sur
la la réalité de la la pénibilité au
travail des femmes dans la police
il faudrait voir qu'est-ce qui se fait
concrètement
enfin vous soulignez l'absence de prise
en compte c'est ce qu'on se dont on
parlait aussi par rapport aux maladies
professionnelles et la notion de
reconnaissance de Malaisie
professionnelle et sur ça c'est vraiment
un domaine où il faut vraiment faire un
gros effort
sur les aspects
activités sportives aussi enfin ce qui
est intéressant c'est que dans nos
discussions c'est tellement flagrant que
la santé c'est une question de société
et donc si c'est une question de société
c'est aussi une question économique et
une question politique et
on en est là c'est pour ça aussi qu'on
est là aujourd'hui ça fait plaisir
et votre dernière question alors là je
j'aurais beaucoup de réserves sachant
que quand on cite ce genre de choses il
faut avoir des sources
solide et fiable et donc tant qu'on a
passé source là on peut pas se prononcer
oui oui il peut y avoir des troubles
cognitifs quand il y a des manques de
vitamines mais ça c'est vraiment prouvé
la vitamine V12 par exemple ou autre
peut mais vraiment voilà il y a des
études très précises sur des maladies
particulières mais je ne rentrerai pas
dans le cadre des progressistes parce
que moi j'ai absolument aucune étude là
dessus je ne serai pas compétent
je voulais parce que le temps avant je
pense qu'on a quelques minutes c'est
tout oui je voulais je voulais
faire un autre point qui est proche déjà
vous dire que la commission santé du
Haut Conseil
excusez déjà aussi Emmanuel Piet qui
n'est pas pu être présente ça c'est
important rappelez que nos champs
d'activité là c'est l'évaluation des
centres régionaux de prise en charge de
psychotrope
et on attend toujours d'un département
ultramarin qui traîne contact avec nous
pour nous dire ce qu'ils font par
exemple donc là aussi l'absence de
réponse nous peine
deux
on va essayer de faire un état des lieux
de la recherche sur la contraception
masculine et là clairement il y a pas
grand chose qui est fait il y a pas
grand chose qui avance et on se demande
pourquoi bah évidemment on se demande
pourquoi c'est comme c'est comme sur les
problèmes de de prise en charge de la
douleur des règles je sais plus qui
disait ici les hommes avaient des règles
le problème serait réglé depuis
longtemps je pense que c'est vrai
troisième sujet c'est d'étudier aussi
il y a des réformes qui sont il y a des
lois qui sont essentielles par exemple
le remboursement à 100% des
contraceptifs pour les jeunes femmes
jusqu'à 25 ans voir la réalité de la
prescription gratuite et du
remboursement de de ces prescriptions il
y a quatrième il y a un quatrième il y a
d'autres éléments que je voulais aussi
donc je voulais vous faire part c'est
que on demande toujours le remboursement
des préservatifs féminins
progressivement sont remboursés pas les
préservatifs féminin c'est quand même
important puisque ça permet quand même
aux femmes de d'imposer le préservatif
et voilà donc c'est quand même important
et sur l'IVG bien évidemment
en étant une protection illestée et
l'autre est considéré comme étant
uniquement une protection les deux sont
Issa c'est aussi donc c'est vraiment
c'est c'est un outil pour la femme elle
peut le mettre une heure avant les
rapports c'est elle qui donc c'est
vraiment important mais c'est toujours
pas remboursé et puis sur l'IVG bien
évidemment la recommandation de la
d'inscrire dans la Constitution soit je
crois qu'on est tous d'accord il faut
vraiment qu'on y arrive et sur l'IMG
aussi c'est
pas toi tout d'accord bon ben en tous
les cas ça fait partie des
recommandations du Haut Conseil et je
pense que le danger qu'on voit poindre
dans nombreux États du monde sur le
droit des femmes à avorter nous nous
amène à penser que c'est une sécurité
obligatoire à mettre en place
et dernière chose sur l'IMG sur les
interruptions médicales de grossesse les
associations
et nous pensons que il faut faire
attention vous savez il peut y avoir des
IMG pour cause fœtale et cause
maternelle pour les sociétales il y a un
jury avec un médecin du centre de du
diagnostic prénatal qui avec d'autres
avec d'autres professionnels vont juger
de
la réalisation de l'IMG et il y a des
causes maternelles et dans les causes
maternelles il peut y avoir un médecin
de la patiente il y a les causes de
détresse psychosociale il peut y avoir
un médecin désigné par la patiente il
peut y avoir un médecin gynécologue et
il y a aussi un médecin appartenant au
centre de diagnostic prénatal et là ça
pose problème puisque c'est pas les
causes prédatales qui sont en cause
c'est la détresse psychosociale de la
patiente et donc là peut-être qu'il
faudrait revoir le
du jury voilà je m'excuse d'avoir été
[Musique]
au territoire ultramarin oui non non il
y a un centre régional qui a été qui est
comment dire j'étais accordé un
financement pour un centre régional de
trauma qui a été accordé
dans un département ultramarin nous les
convoquons pour pouvoir les auditionner
voir ce qui a été réellement fait quelle
est la situation pour l'instant on a
toujours pas de réponse voilà si vous
permettez une deux secondes en fait bon
je ne sais pas de territoire il s'agit
mais dans notre dans un rapport de la
délégation
des Outre-mer concernant les risques
naturels majeurs alors ce rapport de
ça fait partie des préconisations que
nous avons faites nous avons demandé
qu'il y ait une vie réelle prise en
compte des psychotomas et récemment il y
a eu un premier président en juillet le
7 juillet 2022 parce qu'entre temps il y
a eu toute la pandémie et tout avec la
dgom la direction générale des Outre-mer
donc service du ministère des outre-mer
et il y a eu il y a environ un mois un
autre bilan d'étape suite au
à la tempête Fiona qui a touché
essentiellement la Guadeloupe et là dans
la communauté de prise de la délégation
c'est que c'est explicitement mentionné
parce que c'est une des demandes que
j'ai renouvelé pour qu'il y ait la prise
en charge aussi et qui est centrée
journal alors c'est pour là pour les les
psychotromades donc je ne sais pas par
contre quel département donc je vais
essayer de me renseigner je viendrai
vous voir pour qu'on essaie de d'obtenir
des informations
de la RSE de Guadeloupe que j'ai
rencontré il y a pas bien longtemps
merci très bien je suis un dernier point
pour dire quelque chose avancent quand
même pour la première fois au congrès de
Messi général France en mars il y aura
une séance plénière sur Jean et santé
voilà
oui je voulais
vous parler pour terminer quand même
d'un
des activités du groupe genre et
recherche en santé que je coanime avec
une collègue au sein du comité d'éthique
de l'Inserm donc ce groupe a été nous
l'avons créé en 2013 donc ça vous montre
quand même que sur le plan des des
questionnements dans la recherche on a
fait pas mal progresser les choses en
fait depuis 2013 avec des rapports des
guides des recommandations pratiques
quand je parle de recherche c'est pas
uniquement recherche clinique
biomédicales c'est aussi sciences
humaines et sociales c'est au sens large
sur les questions santé publique etc
donc l'Inserm a organisé
en 2007 le premier grand colloque
international sur ces questions là donc
ça veut dire que la France quand même
commence à prendre un peu de place
nous avons aussi au comité d'éthique
fait des clips vidéos que je vous
recommande qui s'appelle Jean récenté à
ascension au clichés fait par des grands
professionnels qui sont très souvent
utilisés pour sensibiliser
non seulement le grand public mais enfin
dans dans différents réunions colloques
institution c'est ces petits clips
vidéos qui sont très très éloquents sont
utilisés donc il y a rare qu'un comité
d'éthique fasse des clips vidéos en
général un comité d'éthique ça veut dire
gros rapports et notre dernier rapport
concerne je vous renvoie au site de
l'Inserm
concerne un problème dont il faudra
s'emparer sérieusement à savoir les
problèmes éthiques en l'occurrence
posées par les applications numériques
de suivi menstruel
à des fins de contraception et de
conception à savoir que il existe des
milliers de ces applications que l'on
trouve sur smartphone qui sont utilisés
par des centaines de millions de femmes
dans le monde
ces applications sont le fait de société
privée qui utilisent en fait la méthode
Ogino numérique pour prédire les dates
d'ovulation et les périodes de fertilité
des femmes donc on est vraiment face à
un gros problème à savoir qu'il n'y a
aucune fiabilité
dans les prédictions qui sont données
par ces applications et qu'il y a aussi
un énorme problème qui est celui de la
protection des données
qui sont renseignées sur ces
applications numériques donc on a deux
il y a deux sujets extrêmement
importants et comme ça concerne des
millions de femmes partout dans le monde
y compris dans les pays du Sud
je crois que il faudra un jour s'emparer
de vraiment de cette question
justement au niveau le plus haut
merci pour votre attention merci madame
monsieur pour ces interventions au titre
du HCE forcément elles vont éclairer les
quatre co-rapporteurs qui vous ont
interrogés ce matin sur la détermination
du sujet santé des femmes qui souhaitent
être
pris à bras le corps au cours de cette
session je on n'a pas identifié
totalement de de d'angle mort ou de
niche mais peut-être qu'il y a quand
même des sujets qui méritent qu'on s'y
attels j'ai repéré notamment santé des
femmes et travail je retiens un sujet
très très important qui qui
apparaissait en filigrane j'ai aussi à
travers cela ça fera forcément écho à
santé des femmes famille monoparentales
je crois que c'est aussi travail famille
et dans le travail on voit organisation
du temps personnel du temps
professionnel du temps de trajet comme
vous l'avez évoqué
l'A aux soins et qui étaient un sujet
que nous avions également abordé dans
famille ruralité avec ce déficit de
gynécologie médicale et donc cette
absence de prévention de de traitement
de et de donc d'informations également
les inégalités socio-économiques sont
revenus souvent dans vos propos
liminaires avec l'impact que ça peut
avoir et donc à travers ces inégalités
économiques ont ça fait qu'aussi à santé
des femmes et travail évidemment et
organisation famille monoparentale donc
on voit tout ça s'articule un petit peu
et puis plusieurs fois vous avez
mentionné
la santé mentale la dépression et le
fait que ça touche je crois me souvenir
trois fois plus de femmes que deux fois
deux fois pardon on exagérons pas non
plus mais je ne suis pas du Sud donc je
suis de l'Ouest donc normalement j'ai
pas cette tendance à l'egger à
l'exagération donc la dépression fait
deux fois plus de femmes donc il y a
vraiment un sujet quand même pour moi
qui se dessine mais ça sera aux quatre
co-rapporteurs de de sens et de de
s'imprégner de cette audition pour
pouvoir cibler ce sujet mais
véritablement Santé Travail famille
monoparentales organisation
dans la société actuelle puisqu'on sait
aussi que les femmes sont plus souvent
dans des travail à temps partiel avec
des temps hachés qui rendent difficile
leur quotidien
[Musique]